I thank you for coming especially
tonight because we are in such
exhilarating times and I thought that uh
a real good analogy of what I've been
thinking over the last couple weeks is
Plato's cave. Do you remember did you
read Plato's Republic when you were in
college? And did you read the analogy of
the cave where Socrates explains that
people who are not involved in
philosophy, who are not thinking about
the great questions, who are not trying
to learn about the truth of things are
like people who live in a cave and have
lived there all their lives. and they
have their backs to the light and they
watch shadows on the wall and they have
names for the various shadows on the
wall and they are very involved with the
shadows. And then he likens learning
philosophy to coming out of the cave
into the bright
sunlight and you can suddenly see the
reality of the things behind the
shadows.
And he says that there are some people
who prefer the cave and the
shadows. Well, what we have been living
in since January 20th is Plato's cave
and the emergence from
it. I was asked on the way over here,
uh, how do you feel since January 20th?
And I said, every day is Christmas.
something else happens that's
wonderful that is it's so
extraordinary I can't believe it after 8
years even I had gotten used to the idea
even I had there's nothing we can do or
at very least nothing is going to be
done and we're all just going to slide
down into destruction and
defeat and now suddenly there's this
huge push back but we do See, there are
a great many people who prefer the cave
and the shadows to the reality of
things. And so, this is not going to be
easy. But imagine if Hillary Clinton had
been president right now and we would
just be continuing on that same
inexurable, apparently inexurable slide
to the dissolution of Judeo-Christian
civilization, to the destruction of the
United States and to the extinguishing
of free societies in the world for an un
unknowable
period. And now there's hope. I can't I
I can barely see for the bright
sunlight and I love it. I hope you do
too and are not longing for the cave in
the shadows. But if you are, we do have
security men here
tonight.
So I've been asked to speak about a
couple of ways in which this is playing
out. And in one of them, in the first
one, it's really rather inconclusive as
to how and when we're going to see the
reality of things. It's only that we
have been promised by President Trump
that things are going to turn around.
And that is in regard to Israel and the
United Nations Resolution
2334. And I'm I'm sure that you're all
familiar with it. It was an
extraordinary betrayal of a faithful
ally by the Obama administration in its
last days. The UN has passed many
similar resolutions over the years
condemning Israel for doing things that
were perfectly legitimate in terms of
Israel's right to self-defense and
ownership of the land on which it is
based. And the United States would
always veto them. But of course, as you
all know, the United States did not veto
this and allowed it to pass. It passed
actually unanimously in the UN Security
Council a prohibition, a criminalization
of any Israeli construction on any land
that was won in the 1967 war.
Now, that is an
extraordinary document because it
essentially is saying that the the parts
of Jerusalem that include the Temple
Mount and the Western Wall actually are
occupied Palestinian land. And this is
in line with a UNESCO resolution from a
few months ago that actually did say
that that said that the Temple Mount is
Palestinian.
It is not a Jewish
site. Now, anybody who's been there and
anybody who's studied any of the history
of the region or anybody who's opened a
Bible will know that there is no more
Jewish site than the site of the temple
of Solomon and the previous temple.
There is no more Jewish site than
Jerusalem in general. And the United
Nations is now on record declaring that
those are not Jewish sites. They do not
belong to Israel. And Israel is
violating international law if it builds
on those sites. This is an outrage to
history, to reason, to truth as well as
to international law as it has
previously been established in numerous
ways.
The whole of that area was marked out
for Jewish settlement by the League of
Nations after the the the dissolution of
the Ottoman Empire in World War I. After
World War
I, not only that, but the countries that
Israel defeated in
1967 were all determined to destroy
Israel
utterly. and Israel uh took over those
territories in order to protect itself
and in with a perfectly legitimate right
of self-defense and of the right of
conquest in
wartime. The right of conquest in
wartime is something that has been
universally recognized for every country
in the world everywhere in history all
over the globe except for
Israel. Do you know the great since I
started out talking about a philosopher
I'll mention another the uh the
philosopher the German philosopher from
the 18th century Emanuel Kant Emanuel
Kant was born and died in the German
city of
Koigsburg which was an ancient German
city going back to medieval times and he
lived there all his life. He never left
there. And uh, oddly enough, because he
was kind of an eccentric, he made part
of his living giving travalogues and
they were very popular. He people would
come from all over to hear him
describe various sites, Rome, the
Vatican, Jerusalem, wherever. He he he
had been all over and he knew all about
them. Except he hadn't. He'd never been
anywhere outside Koigburg. He just read
books about them.
And what if you wanted to go to
Koigsburg today? You can't. It does not
exist. It is Kinenrad in Russia. Why?
Because Hitler invaded the Soviet Union.
And the Soviet Union defeated him and
took over a great deal of German
territory. After World War II, it was
assigned to Russia, to Poland, and to
other
states. Nobody raises a murmur of
protest. There is no right that Germans
have to claim Koigsburg as a German
city. Hitler was embarked on an evil
scheme and as evil as the Soviets were,
they won that city fair and square. And
they still hold it. Nobody would say a
thing about it. And there are thousands,
literally thousands of examples like
that I could give you. But when it comes
to
Israel, suddenly that's off the table.
when that is real international law.
International law, the United Nations
has been around since 1945, but nations
have been around since time immemorial,
and that's always how things have been
settled.
What's more, of course, the uh the 8
mile wide border at the at the at at its
slimmest extent that Israel would have
without some of the lands from when in
1967 would essentially guarantee the
eventual destruction of
Israel. I mean, 8 miles that you have to
defend. So, one mistake and you're done
for.
And at least the country is
biseected and uh dismembered and
ultimately destroyed
altogether. And so President Trump of
course before he isn't that nice to say.
I like to say that President Trump you
know eight years I would always refer to
Barack Obama. I never once referred to
President Obama. Now you can say oh no
Spencer you're wrong because I read an
article that's you said President Obama.
Some editor put that in. I never once
wrote it or said it. But President
Trump, doesn't that sound nice?
Um, and it's not that uh it's not that,
you know, he's got an especially winning
personality or uh a morally upright uh
background. It's that he's actually
doing things to defend the United
States. And it's so it's well, like I
say, the the sun is so bright I can I'm
blinking to try to see the reality of
things.
Now, it's very important that he keeps
his word on this and repudiates that
resolution and defends Israel at the UN
or if he even better defunds the UN and
gets it out of America, then what we
need to do in any case is very much
strengthen that alliance and reaffirm
our commitment to the safety and the
continued existence
of Israel. Now, this
is not just a matter of loyalty to an
ally and not just a matter of doing what
is right by any other nation,
particularly one to with which we are
allied, but it's also an essential
aspect of our defense against the the ji
the global jihad. The war against Israel
is a jihad. A jihad is a struggle to
establish Islamic law over a land on
which it is not yet established. That's
what jihad is all about. It's not just
about blowing things up for the fun of
it. It's about destabilizing non-Muslim
governments so that they ultimately fall
and are replaced with Muslim state,
Muslim governments, Islamic law
governments.
Israel of course in the Islamic view has
no right to exist and will never have
any right to exist because of what is
written in the Quran. So you would open
your Qurans to chapter
2 verse
191. You didn't bring
it. It's okay. I brought mine. I read
the Quran so you don't have to.
[Laughter]
Chapter 2, verse
191 is one of the most charming verses
in this most cuddly of
books. Kill them whenever you find them
and drive them out from where they drove
you out. It's very simple. Kill them
wherever you find them and drive them
out from where they drove you out. Drive
them out from where they drove you out
is actually the key part of this for our
concern our purposes tonight. Drive them
out from where they drove you out means
that no land that has ever belonged to
Muslims or been ruled by Muslims can
ever legitimately in the eyes of Islam
be ruled by
non-Muslims. Drive them out from where
they drove you out. It's a very simple
principle. So see if for example the
Muslims had a caliphate in
Spain and the non-Muslims drove them
out. Well, then the Muslims have a
responsibility before Allah, delineated
in the Quran, commanded in the Quran to
drive out the non-Muslims from Spain and
re-establish Islamic rule. And it's the
same situation for Israel. And actually,
when you read al-Qaeda in particular is
exercised about Spain, but ISIS, the
Islamic State has also written about it.
And it is a very
high element item on the jihadi wish
list. They want to destroy Israel and
then they want to reconquer Spain
because it's in the Quran. Drive them
out from where they drove you out. It
couldn't be
simpler. This is Allah speaking to the
Muslims. This is something they have to
do in order to please Allah. So when
there
are Camp David Accords and Oslo Accords
and road maps
and everything else that has been
attempted to try to bring peace between
Israel and the
Palestinians, they are all doomed to
failure before they even
start. And they will never ever work.
They will never bring
peace because there will always be
Muslims in that area who believe they
have a responsibility before their God
to drive them out from where they drove
you
out. And so what is the solution? The
solution is only to be
strong, to understand
this, to unapologetically assert and
insist that this is land that is the
land of Israel and be determined to
defend it. But understand, this is not
something that's going to be
solved. Now, you know, we want a
solution. TV shows are 30 minutes long
or an hour long and we want it all to be
wrapped up by the end.
But there is just no solution to this
problem. There's only management of it.
And the only management of it can come
from military, cultural, spiritual,
societal
strength. If any one of those is
missing, then there's going to be
trouble. And one of the reasons why we
have so much trouble is that many of
those elements have been missing in
whole or part on the part of many
Israelis as on as well as on the part of
the American left.
And so the first
key to any kind
of solution for Israel in terms of any
kind of way that it can continue to
exist in safety and security is to
understand that all these negotiations
and peace efforts are the wrong way to
go.
Now, Donald Trump has not shown any
indication of being aware of this, but
he has shown a strong determination to
defend Israel and to keep the jihadis
from encroaching further upon it. But it
was very disquing when the other day it
came out a very strange statement from
his press secretary that was one of the
few sour notes and equivocal notes that
we have heard from this White House
since January 20th. And that was that uh
it was sort of a strange thing. You
remember it said maybe there maybe those
settlements aren't such a good idea.
Maybe they are an obstacle to peace. And
then it said the president is not
intending to make here an official
statement on the settlements. So that's
good. We have a little bit of breathing
room but it was not a good
sign. What the president I hope will do
is look at the example of even recent
history. 10 years ago, we were told that
Gaza was in in ferment and on fire
because Israelis were there establishing
settlements and it was Palestinian land.
And the Israelis agreed, which they
really never ought to do, and they left
and forcibly dismantled those
settlements. And the American publisher
Mortimer Zukerman spent $14 million to
buy green houses that the Israelis had
established in Gaza and gave them to the
Palestinians so that they would be able
to have gainful employ of something to
occupy their time. The idea was Zukerman
clearly thought and many many other
people clearly thought that if the
Israelis go, if they end the occupation,
if they stop the settlement
construction, then the Palestinians will
be pacified. They will stop the war,
they will go about their business, they
will start to uh do peace, pursue
peaceful occupations, and they have
these green houses they can work in.
They have other things they can do. What
did they do? They immediately gutted the
greenh houses and made them into weapon
smuggling tunnels.
The uh the outpo outpoint of many of the
weapon smuggling tunnels from the Sinai
was these green houses. And they only
stepped up the jihad against Israel. It
didn't
lessen. They didn't stop fighting the
Israelis. They started lobbing rockets
into Israel so that Israel has several
times now had to go in to Gaza and then
immediately we always
hear, excuse me, how disproportionate
the Israeli response is and so
on. There is nothing
disproportionate about dealing with a
people that wants to destroy you
utterly.
I am not in the slightest bit saying
that the Palestinians should be
destroyed utterly, but to take measures
that appear to be harsh or are portrayed
as harsh. And of course, the the
grievance propaganda industry in Gaza is
very strong and sophisticated and has
continually been found to have
manufactured atrocities by the IDF. And
then they go out into the international
news and it's only much later we find
out that the whole thing was fake.
But in any
case, the reality is sometimes
difficult. And this is a group if you
look at the Middle East Media Research
Institute or Palestinian Media Watch and
you see what they see on TV all the time
in in Gaza, you would be amazed at the
open calls for genocide of the Jews. The
open anti-semitism, the the the the
hatred and the venom that is so very
deep. And it ultimately goes back to the
Quran which not only says drive them out
from where they drove you out, but if
you turn to chapter 5:82, it says that
the Jews among all people will be the
worst enemies of the Muslims, which in
practice generally works out to being
that the Muslims are the most hostile to
the
Jews and they see them as some sort of
uh subhuman beasts that are in deeply
evil. Ayanhiri Ali, the famous ex-Muslim
feminist w grew up a Muslim in Somalia
and then later she uh immigrated to
Europe and speaks about seeing Jews for
the first time and being shocked and
seeing they're just ordinary people. She
thought they were sort of uh gargoyless
in in in semihuman form stalking around
doing evil on the earth. And this is
what these people are told all the time.
exactly this kind of thing. If you look
at the Quran's teaching on the Jews, it
says that they uh are under a curse of
Allah for claiming that Ezra is the son
of God, which of course they don't. Uh
chapter 9:30 of the Quran, it says that
humiliation and disgrace follows them
wherever they are, which is chapter 2
verse 89. And this is something that
becomes a responsibility upon incumbent
upon the Muslims to make sure if Jews
are not living humiliated and disgraced
then the Muslims have to make sure that
they are because it's in the
Quran. If humiliation and disgrace
follow them wherever they are then if
they don't have it it has to be brought
upon them.
They essentially are haters of Allah,
haters of the good, the killers of the
prophets uh and and and the enemies of
the Muslims that are most skillful and
indehaticable and
inveterate against this backdrop. If
somebody's reading this book then as the
eternal and perfect words of the one and
only
God, then how are you going to see some
negotiated settlement?
How are you going to see the existence
of Israel at all? it has to be
destroyed. And so it is good to see that
we have a president now for the first
time in so very long who is interested
in defending Israel. I hope that people
around him will be telling him some of
these things so that we don't continue
to waste our time on peace accords that
are never going to do anything and have
all too often been used to force
concessions upon the Israelis that are
dangerous for their own security and
continued survival, but that instead we
will devote our efforts and our
resources to genuine steps that can
defend Israel. The other
thing, excuse
me, the other thing that is uh of course
very large in the news these days is the
President Trump President Trump uh
President Trump's immigration ban, his
Muslim ban as it's being called. 87% of
the Muslims in the world are not
affected by it.
And yet it is being completely demonized
and vilified as a Muslim band. The
people who were prefer the shadows of
Plato's cave to reality are ignoring
some very important facts in trying to
vilify this ban and get it done away
with altogether. And of course, right
now it's not in effect. the uh a federal
judge called for it to be halted and
then the Justice Department, President
Trump's Justice Department has
challenged that ban and called for a
stay on on a stay on the ban of the
ban and they're going to be fighting
about this for a long time.
But though actually American law is
quite explicit and very clear that the
president has the right and the
responsibility to make immigration
restrictions of any
kind without any kind of exception made
in that
law in order to safeguard the security
of the American people. Now, is keeping
people out from places like Yemen and
Somalia a good idea? And does it have to
do with national security? Or is it just
a racist, bigoted, anti-Muslim step that
shows that the alt-right neo-Nazi white
supremacists have taken over Washington
and the sky is falling?
We could we need to look at reality in
order to answer that question and it's
really very simple. The Islamic State as
ISIS calls itself. If you remember ISIS
or ISIL as the former president used to
call it and the former president
and that group actually calls itself the
Islamic State since June 29th 2014 has
proclaimed itself to be the sole
legitimate government for Muslims on
earth and indeed for non-Muslims. The
caliphate the successor of Muhammad. The
caiff is the successor of Muhammad as
the military, political and spiritual
leader of the Muslims. And this
entity now occupies a large expanse of
Iraq and Syria. At its highest point, it
occupied a land larger than Great
Britain.
And it because of its claim to be the
caliphate which has been endorsed by
many other Muslim groups. It also has
allegiance of groups that hold
significant expanses of land in Libya,
in Nigeria, in Yemen and elsewhere. It
is an international movement and it has
declared war on the United States in no
uncertain terms. In September
2014, there was it issued a lengthy
fatwa, a religious ruling explaining why
it was the Muslims duty to kill
Americans and to kill others. It
especially singled out what it called
the spiteful and filthy French. And we
saw again an attack at the Louv in Paris
just days ago. And it said that you are
to kill Americans and kill other uh
westerer western non-Muslims in any way
that you can use an IED. If you don't
have an IED, then shoot them. If you
don't have a gun, then stab them. If you
don't have a knife, run them over with
your car. And we've seen a lot of that.
There's been a lot of that in Israel as
well.
Now, this group, the Islamic State, in
calling for the murders of American
civilians, also made it very clear in
February 2015. It said, "We are going to
flood Europe with 500,000
refugees." They said it straight out.
We're going to flood Europe with 500,000
refugees. Now, 500,000 refugees, what
would that do to Europe? Well, we're
seeing because they came. What a
coincidence.
And what would they do to Europe? Well,
first thing they would do is overwhelm
the welfare systems of those welfare
states because they don't come and work.
Because the Quran in chapter 9 29, you
can turn there. It says that Muslims
must fight against the people of the
book who are primarily Jews and
Christians until they pay the Jiza
attacks with willing submission and feel
themselves subdued. which is essentially
saying that in the proper scheme of
things, it's the responsibility of Jews
and Christians to pay for the upkeep of
the Muslims to pay this tax that
supports the the
Muslims. And so if the non-Muslims are
not paying the tax, the Muslims have the
right to take their resources by theft
or to take advantage of their welfare
systems and so on. So they're not
working and they're overwhelming the
welfare systems. But above all, they are
engaging in all kinds of behavior that
is creating tremendous upheaval in
European societies. For one thing, in
November 2015, Islamic jihadis attacked
at several points in Paris and murdered
130 people.
all of those attackers, it did not come
out immediately, but it has now been
established that every last one of those
attackers was a refugee who had just
come into
Europe. And so you think about, well,
the Islamic State said, "We're going to
send
refugees." They were going to embed
jihadis among the refugees, and they
have done so. Not only that, but the
refugees have committed an absolute
pandemic of rapes and sexual assaults.
Now, this is very unpleasant, but it's
all in the Quran. This is based upon the
Quran. If you turn to chapter
4:3, I don't know why you don't have it.
I take mine wherever I go.
Anyway, says uh marry the women that
seem good to you. Two or three or four.
And then it says, "If you fear that you
will not be able to treat them justly,
then marry one or from among those your
right hands possess." Who are those your
right hands
possess? Well, I happen to have here I
like to carry this one around. You can
see I've carried it around a lot because
uh this this is a uh certified moderate
Quran and we need to empower the
moderates. You've all heard that.
and I was in London. I I can't go there
anymore because I committed the crime of
saying that Islam has a doctrine of
violence against
unbelievers. Stay tuned to see if uh the
prime minister of Great Britain will
start banning people who say that water
is wet. But in any case, I was in London
a few years back and I uh did what any
American tourist would do in London. I
toured the mosques. And
so I was at the Finsbury Park Mosque
which was notorious a few years back. Uh
Abu Hamza was the uh imam there. He was
a very notorious character. You may have
seen pictures of him. He had uh at one
point in an excess of piety uh blown
himself up and he uh had lost his eye
and both of his hands. So he had this uh
uh strange white eye with no pupil and
hooks for hands and he was the imam at
this mosque and they preached jihad
terror. He is now in prison in the
United States for his part in a
conspiracy to establish an al-Qaeda
training camp in Bllye,
Oregon. And anyway, Abu Hamza is gone
now. He was gone when I went there. And
I said to the very nice young man who
was loading me up with books hoping to
convert me to Islam. It didn't work.
And he was very friendly, very
courteous. And I said, "I hear you had
some trouble here a few years back." And
he said, "Yes, he has uh there were some
extremists here, but they're all gone.
And now we're all
moderates. All of them." And so he gave
me this moderate Quran. This Quran is a
translation of the Arabic text with
commentary by say Abu Alam Maudi. Maudi
was a Pakistani Islamic scholar and
politician. He was the founder of Jamaad
Islami which is still the largest
political party in Pakistan that wants
to establish the fullness of Islamic
law. Maldudi died in 1979 and his works
on the Quran he wrote a multi-olume
commentary on the Quran of which this is
a digest and his works on the Quran you
can find it next time you go to your
local Muslim
bookstore ask for books by Maldudi I
guarantee you they will have them he's
not considered extremist he's very
mainstream and so when you go in
remember Maudi anyway
I'm going to let him explain what the
captives of the right hand, those whom
your right hands possess are. There are
several other verses. I won't take your
time to read them all, but there are
several other verses relating to these
people that it makes it clear that a
Muslim man can have sexual relations
with them even though he's not married
to them. And this is what he says. Maudi
this expression the those whom your
right hands possess denotes slave girls
i.e.
female captives of war who are
distributed by the state among
individuals when no exchange of
prisoners of war takes place. Now you
may have heard ISIS doing this and
kidnapping large numbers of Yazidian
Christian girls and using them in this
way and it's the same thing in Europe
where you also have the Quran verse
chapter
33:59. You remember that one? I'm sure
you have it needle pointed on your
wall.
Um it says, "Oh prophet, enjoin your
wives and your daughters and the
believing women to draw a part of their
outer garments over them. It is likelier
that they will be recognized and not
molested." Recognized that is as Muslims
if they're all covered up and not
molested. So you see the women who are
not going to be molested have to be
veiled, have to have their heads
covered, their faces covered, whatever.
But if you are not thus covered up, then
you can be
molested. That's the the the subtext
here that if you don't want your if you
want to be molested, then don't dress in
this way. Draw don't draw a part of your
outer covering over them. So these
Muslim guys come into Europe and they
see these women who are not all veiled
and they think these are non-Muslim
women. Non-Muslim women can be taken as
captives of the right hand and they're
not veiled so they can be
molested. And so this is the they're the
rape epidemic in Germany in Sweden. It's
Sweden is now the rape capital of the
world because of mus Muslim migrants.
So, President Trump, you remember
President Trump, he wants to keep this
kind of thing from happening here. And
one of the very sparsely reported but
extraordinary aspects of his ban on
these countries, and that's only a
beginning. A lot of people say, well,
wait a minute, why wasn't Saudi Arabia?
Why wasn't
Afghanistan? A lot of things, a lot of
countries ought to be added to the list.
And that's some good news that Rice
Priebus' chief of staff did say recently
that some countries may be added to the
list. But first they have to establish
that the list can be done at all that we
have any right to defend ourselves.
But the extraordinary thing about the
executive order is that it says that the
United States should and must keep
people out who want to put religious law
over civil law, who want
to have practic bring over practices
such as honor killings and the violence
against people who are of a different
religion or violence against women. Now,
of course, Islam justifies all those
things. And so, it was very clear what
it was all about. And the idea that the
United States could keep those people
out and should keep those people out,
it's very simple. It's either do that or
face the kind of societal upheaval that
we're seeing in Europe and will be
seeing in Europe for years to come.
Either we keep out some people who are
legitimate travelers and will not cause
any trouble or we bring in people among
whom will be an unknowable number of
Islamic jihad mass murderers and people
who believe in Islamic law to the extent
that they will take women and molest
them and go on welfare and never do any
good for anybody and they will cause
immense disruption to American society.
It's an
eitheror. You either inconvenience some
people who are perfectly nice folks or
we bring upon ourselves a future of mass
murder and societal
upheaval. Now, you say, "Well, that's an
oversimplification." Well, is it really?
Yes, because you can vet. You can vet
the refugees. And even President Trump
has said, "We're going to do extreme
vetting." I don't know what that means.
It sounds good, though.
And the only problem about it is is that
and I think this ultimately is going to
have to be faced by Trump or some uh
future American president is how are you
going to vet these people? Muhammad the
prophet of Islam said war is deceit and
gave permission to lie if a husband
needs to lie to his wife to keep the
marriage smooth. No, honey. I wasn't out
with the captives of the right hand last
night. And in
wartime, and of course, the Islamic
State and other jihadi entities consider
themselves to be at war with the United
States. So war is deceit. So how can you
vet for people if they're going to lie
no matter what question you ask them?
Not only that, but we've already seen
the failure of the Obama vetting
process. Tashi Malik, one of the San
Bernardino shooters who killed 15 people
at a Christmas party on December 2nd,
2015. She had passed five separate
background checks from five different US
agencies. Now, this doesn't mean that
nothing can be done. I think that if you
did have some kind of questioning
regarding support for Israel, regarding
the uh attitudes toward women, toward
honor killings, towards some of the
things that were enumerated in the
executive order, if they were properly
phrased and administered by people who
were
knowledgeable, then they might be very
revealing because even the most
practiced deceiver, and the Quran tells
us that Allah is the best of schemers,
even the most practiced deceiver
cannot cover for things he's not
prepared to lie about. And so if the
questions were cleverly enough crafted,
there may be something that could be
done. But in any case, in the short
term, is a moratorum justified?
It's obviously quite justified by law,
justified by
necessity, justified by the statements
of the jihad entities, justified by the
record of what's happened in
Europe, justified by the teachings of
Islam in regard to not only the things
that I've enumerated
already, but also the concept of excuse
me, I'm 13 years old. The concept of uh
im immigration in general, immigration
moving from one land to another is
actually central in Islam. It's a
central Islamic concept. It's not
tangential or incidental. It is central.
As a matter of fact, the Islamic
calendar, the Islamic calendar, do you
know what the year one of the Islamic
calendar is? The Hijra. It's not when
Muhammad was
born. Excuse me. It's not when Muhammad
died. It's not when Muhammad became a
prophet. It's the Hijra. The HRA is the
immigration when Muhammad moved from
Mecca to Medina and became for the first
time a military and political leader as
well as a spiritual one.
And so the idea of making that year 1 in
the Islamic calendar is tacitly
saying Islam is not really Islam until
it's political and military and not just
religious. That's one point. But it's
also established as being political and
military by means of immigration.
Chapter 4 verse 100 of the
Quran
says, "He who
immigrates, he who immigrates in the way
of Allah will find in the earth enough
room for refuge and plentiful resources.
And he who goes forth from his house as
a migrant in the way of Allah and his
messenger and whom death overtakes, his
reward becomes incumbent on Allah."
Now, in the in the Quran, in Islam,
there's no savior. There's no
redemption. They're just the scales. If
your good deeds outweigh your bad deeds,
you go to paradise. If your bad deeds
outweigh your good deeds, you go to
hell. And so, when there's something
that's promised a reward from Allah,
that's extremely important because
that's a big thing on your good deed
scale to immigrate in the way of a law.
But immigrating in the way of a law does
not mean moving to the United States to
get a good job and send money back to
Pakistan. Moving in the way of Allah,
immigrating in the way of Allah means
you are bringing Islam to the new place.
That's what it's all
about. And that means everything that it
means. the subjugation of the infidels,
the subjugation of women, the
extinguishing of the freedom of speech,
the honor violence, much more. If you
bring that to a new land, you will be
rewarded by Allah. Now, do any Muslims
take this seriously in the United
States? Let me give you I will close
with one example. A few years back,
there was a school in
Minnesota called the Tar Iben Zed
Academy. It was a charter school which
means it received federal funds and yet
it was essentially a an Islamic school.
All the students were Muslims. They had
Quran class. They had prayers. And so
eventually a controversy began because
of course the prayer in school is
supposed to be not allowed and uh
religious schools are not supposed to
receive government funding. This has all
been established visav Christianity over
the years. And so this school was
challenged and ultimately it was shut
down and ultimately it reopened in the
same place under another name and it's
doing the same things but that's another
story. The point I am making here is
that in all that controversy about TAK
and Zed
Academy I did not see one story where
one reporter had the wit or curiosity to
ask someone there hey who's Takibben
Zed? Is he the John Dwey of Islam? Some
great
educator. Tarak Iban Zed was one of the
conquerors of Spain. And he's famous for
landing on the beach in Spain and
ordering the boats burned. And his
soldiers said, "What are you doing
burning the boats?" And he said, "We're
here to stay. We either die here or we
establish Islam here, but we ain't going
back." Now, what do you think the people
in Minnesota who called saw thought,
hey, let's call it Takib and Zed
Academy, what do you think they have in
mind?
So, it's extraordinary the times we're
living in. And I think it's it's going
to be very difficult. Obviously, there's
no doubt it's going to be very
difficult. But for the first time in so
many years, we have push back actual
attempts to defend Americans against the
global
jihad. And I don't mean just eight
years. I mean quite a bit longer than
that. President Trump is more honest
when he speaks even when just when he
says the words radical Islamic
terrorism. President Trump is more
honest about the nature, the motivating
ideology of the jihad threat than any
president since John Quincy Adams. And
John Quincy was not a candidate in
2016. So what we have, what's happened
now is extraordinary. uh the the the
move toward globalization, the eraser of
national boundaries, the eraser of
ethnic distinctions, and the the
establishment of a socialist
internationalist order was just moving
along swimmingly. And now suddenly a
wrench has been thrown in the works. The
people who love that machine, the people
who love the shadows, they are clearly
very riled up and they're going to keep
coming. But remember the first rule
always in confronting bullies,
confronting evil, stand up to them. If
you stand up and refuse to seed an
inch, then they're the real cowards.
They will run away. And ultimately, I
think that uh I'm well, I'm more
optimistic than I've been in years. We
have a chance to prevail and preserve
free societies now. But we all have to
work and recognize that it's not all
just going to be handed to us now that
we have a president who has a modicum of
sense and is not a globalist determined
to destroy nation states and so on. We
have to work harder than ever to turn
make sure that the forces of oppression,
the forces of darkness are not going to
prevail after all and are not going to
make this just a wonderful interlude
before it's back to the cave.
We will never go back to the cave again.
Thank you.
[Applause]